hey guys i'm 33 years old right now
going on 34
and as most of you might know two-thirds
of all men
in the world experience hair loss and
thinning hair
when they enter into their mid-30s and i
did a lot of research on this
to prevent hair loss and thinning hair
and i also made a couple of videos about
it for you guys
and the knowledge about this helped me
to also slow down my own receding
hairline
and thinning hair which i got from my
granddad
thanks brenden but now
it is time to look at the most powerful
treatment that science can offer us
at home and it is laser hair growth
treatment but how does it work does it
even work or is it just another
money making scheme well that's what i'm
gonna test out in this video
let's not waste any more time let's get
right into it
[Music]
i have a dream
[Music]
all right now i did a lot of research on
laser hair growth therapies
and the best one which is also one of
the only ones out there on the market
that is fda cleared
is the i restore so what i did was i
reached out to them
and i asked them hey guys i would love
to test out
your product but i would also love to
make an
honest review video about it now most
companies don't really like it
when you say honest review but irish
store was different
they were very excited and after a
couple of days
they sent me their irish store hair
growth
system so let's unbox it let me show you
what i got
and then i'm going to test it out for
three months
wow all right this is it guys look at
the lights over here the lasers and the
led lights
all right here we go um i was more
interested in this guy but they sent me
all of these stuff which is pretty
awesome
got the anti-thinning conditioner and
shampoo
then we got the hair gummy vitamins over
here which is pretty cool because his
biotin antioxidants vitamin c and e and
coconut oil
looks interesting and then we got the
anti-hair loss serum
and then also this guy over here which
is a three in one hair growth
formula so it all looks good
but the question is does it really work
well i'm gonna find out i'm gonna test
them out for three months
to see if they work and i'm gonna show
you
so while i test it out let me quickly
explain to you the science behind it
iristor uses low laser hair therapy to
help your hair follicles to produce
hair again how does it work well the
iristor uses high quality
medical grade lasers and leds to help
your cells absorb the light energy
and then to increase their metabolism
rate and their atp
production so in short when your cells
start to be more active again
those dormant hair follicles start to
work
again and then you're starting to grow
your hair
like you used to faster and thicker now
this is not just for men but for women
as well it also comes with a mobile
battery
i charged it only once and i was able to
use it seven
times before i had to charge it again
now there's a few things that you need
to know about the eye
restore it is clinically proven to
regrow
hair it's got a 12 month money back
guarantee with
no restocking fees and free return so it
means you can send it back if you don't
see any
results now you won't see the results
within the first few weeks but you can
expect to see
visible results in three to six months
but of course
individual results may be different now
so far
i've been using it for a month with
these results
[Music]
[Music]
so in 120 days my hair was not falling
out anymore
it was slowly growing back fuller
thicker and faster and to be honest
it was a little bit slower than i
expected it to be
and so i just wanted to test it for
three months and then i decided no i'm
gonna
test it a little bit longer so i gave it
another month four months
but then i wanted to test it out even
more
for a full year but using it only once
or twice
a week not every day so that's what i
did
and to be honest there was actually a
week here and there
that i totally forgot about using the
iris store
but it's now been a full year and this
is
the result
now as you can see my hair still looks
good i did not lose any more hair
it looks thicker and there's more hair
but you need to know that it might work
differently for different people check
out the customer reviews on amazon
with their before and after photos as
well now if you do want to give it a try
remember to be patient because most
people actually only see a big
difference after four months
so be patient and if it doesn't work for
you remember they've got a 12
month money back guarantee so you can
send it back if it doesn't work for you
and of course i'll add all the details
and the links for you in the video
description
down below so you can check it out now
if there are any of you here watching
the video that's been using the irish
store
please comment in the comment section
down below tell the people
if it works or if it doesn't work for
you i'm sure it's going to help them
and if you're new here on the channel
check out one of these videos
and i'll see you there cheers guys